hey everybody so in this video i'm going
to be showing you how you can get the
banished knights halberd that gives you
a plus eight upgrade as soon as you pick
it up off the ground it can be located
at the southernmost tip of the map at
castlemore
mourn i don't really know how to say
that but once you go into the castle
you'll see the side of grace that you
can rest at and this will be your
checkpoint for the rest of the castle
pretty much you'll go up the elevator
and you will just see a full-scale
battle going on in castlemore it's a
giant fortress and what we are gonna do
instead is ignore
all of these enemies and we're just
gonna run past them that that was what i
did i kind of sent out my jellyfish to
take care of everything you can see how
well it did there by dying immediately
to the pumpkin head on the side you're
going to take a right once you go up the
title of bodies
and you're going to go inside of the
castle down here so you're going to make
your way down the stairs avoiding all
the dogs as best you can and you will
see more fighting going on here that you
can just completely avoid you can go up
the ladder
make your way up the ladder they will
follow you but they're not super fast
and they have their own things to deal
with while you got your own stuff to
deal with too we're trying to find the
hallbird plus eight we don't really care
what these guys are doing we have no
affiliation with any of this stuff even
up here full scale battle still going on
inside the fortress and we just don't
care we're gonna keep
moving along and going up uh if you go
straight across the ladder you'll find
another set of ladders
and you'll go up here and you can jump
off onto a set of like uh like a tent
that can break your fall not take any
damage and you'll fight your way across
this bridge you will hang a left halfway
across this bridge and you'll just see
more fighting everything in this
fortress is fighting against each other
and you can completely ignore it if you
want to which is kind of nice or you can
kill everything get all the echoes that
you could possibly imagine
and there is a boss hidden uh under out
past the castle actually but we don't
care about that we're going for the hull
bird which makes the boss kind of a
pushover if you make your way down this
path you will see uh kind of an end
point to the fortress kind of one of the
towers on one of the sides you make your
way up these stairs and you will come
across this guy
this is an npc sidequest of the father
of irena that you'll meet kind of on the
pathway toward the castle you can talk
to him and unfortunately he gives you a
stick and says everything is lost
and he's the commander and has to go
down with his own castle
during the nbc side quest you can give
him a letter that irene wants you to
give him we were kind of pissed off me
and my twitch chat that uh he gave us a
stick so we decided to kill him not
really expecting what we were gonna get
out of it
we got the banished knights halberd
plus eight you can kind of see my
reaction there i am like are you serious
that is a lot of upgrades to just find
on the ground it's actually kind of
incredible it does a ton of damage does
a ton of critical damage and the art
of war that it comes with is just
amazing we call it the helicopter you
can actually walk and use it at the same
time
it is so
cool and it just mows through
most of the enemies that i've come
across in my 24 hours of playing this
game
so far
i think it's awesome i hope you guys
like it the last thing that i'm going to
show all of you is what happens when you
go back to irena basically we were gonna
tell her that we either killed her dad
or we could lie about it so we go back
down the path which is pretty much a
straight shot outside of the castle it
was kind of funny what we came across so
i hope you guys enjoyed the video hope
you guys enjoy the haul bird if you like
more videos like this please let me know
down in the comments make sure to
subscribe and all that good stuff thanks
for watching the video and i'll see you
in the next one
yeah
things did not end well for arena
did it
examine
she
[Laughter]
you don't say
oh